à oshawa dans un paisible quartier
résidentiel vie jolène guignard un jour
son mari et elle ont reçu du courrier
qui allait bouleverser leur vie des
lettres que tous les contribuables
redoute des avis de redressement de l'
agence du revenu du canada sans
avertissement le fisc leur imposer des
pénalités de presque 70 mille dollars
j'étais vraiment surpris c'est à chaque
âge je ne me donnais pas sans toi ça m'a
fait mal au coeur c'est il faut compter
les pénalités j'ai aucune idée comment
ce qu'on va faire
en 2008 jolène son mari rémy et leurs
amis général bako on cherchait de l'aide
afin de préparer leur déclaration de
revenus des amis leur avait recommandé
un conseiller fiscal la région de
toronto
mountazar azoul la fin des présentations
ça c'est avec nous puis avait des
exemples d'autres tellement fait la même
chose j'ai aussi des remboursements oui
eva des copies des chats qui a bien reçu
puis nous expliquer qu'il veut fait la
recherche dans la loi d'un pont il y
avait trouvé d d d échappatoire fiscaux
dans la loi d'un pont qui nous donnaient
le droit d'être capable d'avoir c'est le
remboursement que campagne le conseiller
fiscal à préparer leurs déclarations
mais après les avoir envoyées à l'agencé
du revenu le fisc a commencé alors posé
des questions sur des pertes
d'entreprise que le conseiller avait
inscrits sur leurs déclarations
aucun d'entre eux n'était propriétaire
d'une entreprise
le soi disant conseiller fiscal faisait
partie d'un groupe devenu connu sous le
nom de fiscaux arbitres russes des
milliers de canadiens ordinaires se sont
fait vendre leurs services fiscaux
douteux l' agence du revenu à porter des
accusations de fraude contre ses
conseillers peu scrupuleux mais le fisc
a également sévi contre tous leurs
clients en leur imposant des pénalités
sévères
l'avocat duane below représente une
cinquantaine de contribuables trompé par
ses présumés fraudeurs mes clients
étaient des cols bleus et les penaltys
représenter sommes énormes entre 50000
au dessus de sa maison alors ton projet
c'est beaucoup d'argent ils risquent
perdre qu'est ce qu'on fait dans leur
vie de leurs biens pour payer ces
pénalités très important les pénalités
étaient hors de proportion avec les dix
à quinze mille dollars que ses clients
avaient reçu en remboursement d'impôt m
me lo a contacté l' agence du revenu
pour faire réduire ces pénalités 20
étaient prêts à intéresser à parler
2 les pénalités ils m'ont dit très
clairement qu'ils pouvaient pas m'aider
et puis aller à la cour d'impôts donc
personne à l' agence pour pouvait
m'aider ils avaient décidé que les
pénalités étaient appliquées pour tout
les contribuables au canada qui ont
participé à ce programme
et puis quelle agence pourra promet des
ça fait six ans qu'ils attendent d'avoir
une audience à la cour de l'impôt il
pour l'instant les intérêts e
s'accumulent
moi j'ai appelé le gouvernement pour
leur dire que j'avais pas de manière à
payer ça on en parle de 100 mille
dollars au plus mais on parlait de ses
aléas
après nos maisons nos salaires voyons
pris mon salaire remonte à un
pourcentage à mon salaire pour au moins
4 5 mois l' agence du revenu n'a montré
aucune clémence envers ces contribuables
de la classe moyenne mais en même temps
le fisc mener une enquête sur un des
plus prestigieux cabinets comptables au
pays
kpmg qui avait aidé des
multimillionnaires à cacher leur fortune
offshore
l'argent était simulé derrière une série
de sociétés écrans enregistré à l'île
demandant la mer d'irlande
selon l' agence du revenu ce stratagème
visait à tromper le fisc
et comme nous l'avons constaté l'année
dernière tout baigné dans secret
selon professeur en droit fiscal
l'université laval andré lareau il
pourrait y avoir même matière à une
enquête criminelle est ce qu on pourrait
même parler d'un code fraude
on pourrait pas d'un contrôle si on peut
prouver l'intention on pourrait
n'arriver à cas de fraude et donc de
poursuites criminelles effectivement l'
agence du revenu savait que kpmg avait
vendu ce stratagème fiscal à plusieurs
autres clients au canada
mais c'était tellement secret que l'
agence ne connaissait pas l'identité de
la plupart d'entre eux et kpmg n'était
pas près de leur révéler quoi que ce
soit c'est à ce moment là que l' agence
obtenu un ordre de la cour forçant kpmg
à leur remettre les noms pendant ce
temps à ottawa des hauts dirigeants de
l' agence de revenus tenait des propos
musclés devant les parlementaires
les règles ont changé si vous faites
l'évasion fiscale et qu'on peut le
prouver
nous poursuivrons avec toute la rigueur
de la loi
même les conseillers fiscaux était
désormais dans la mire de la jambe au
havre prostitution à nos enquêtes
criminelles
nous avons mis les prometteurs à l'avant
champ alors pour nous autres en ce
moment c'est ce qu'ils peuvent voir et à
profite à des genres de programmes
abusif
keynes qui sont vraiment natta point de
mire en ce moment considérant ces
promesses bien faire comment expliquer
ce qui s'est ensuite passé dans dossier
kpmg
la cause en cour fédérale est tombé au
point mort rien ne s'est passé pendant
plus de deux ans
au printemps dernier
kpmg était le commanditaire d'un
discours du ministre des finances de
l'époque à vancouver le maître de
cérémonie était elio luongo
le grand patron des services fiscaux
chez kpmg
nous espérions qu'il pourrait nous
éclairer
au moment même où est liée aux lingots
s'éloignait de nos caméras
lagence du revenu mettait en secret la
dernière main à une offre qu'elle allait
faire aux clientes kpmg
trois jours après que nous ayons
rencontré monsieur luongo discours du
ministre
lagence de revenus a envoyé un document
confidentiel au cabinet comptable
personne d'autre n'était au courant
jusqu'à ce qu'une enveloppe brune et été
expédié au réalisateur harvey cashore à
l'intérieur un document daté du 1er mai
une copie de la fameuse offre de l'
agence du revenu au mystérieux cliente
kpmg
l'entente était à ce point secrète que
si quiconque en divulguer le contenu
elle n'était plus valide et ce n'était
pas les clients qui exigeait toute cette
confidentialité
c'est l agence du revenu elle même et
que conti et elle nous avons laissé m
milo en prendre connaissance
oro
pénalité du tout ça c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable que l' agence a fait 1
entente avec ses clients pour aucune
pénalité pour autant aucune les années
puis ont même eu une réduction de taux
d'intérêt c'est injuste que l'agent ce
fait un offre secrète à déminer en
arrière quand il poursuit me client en a
six années pas de pénalités pas dans
quel criminel
ils n'ont qu'à payer les impôts dus et
des intérêts réduits tête galvan et le
nouveau sous commissaire de l' agence du
revenu responsable des programmes
d'observation
comment pouvez vous expliquer ce deux
poids deux mesures
c'est vrai dans ces deux dossiers l'
agence a détecté un une observation
sévère et a poursuit les participants
pour recueillir les revenus du malgré
cette similarité les faits dans les
dossiers varient et quand l'effet variés
mais les résultats peuvent ensuite
s'annonce assez l'offre ici plus
honnêtement aucun permis n'est donné
jusqu'à mi 1999 aucune comité ça veut
dire que le gouvernement sont capables
de négocier quand qu'ils veulent mais
faute à de l'argent comme nous le
faisons nous pas d'argent dh et sens
capable de faire une entente mais pour
ceux qui travaillent à chaque jour
essayer de faire un salaire gesport
avoir dû manger sous la terre peut avoir
une famille on n'a rien
les libéraux ont fait campagne sur
l'équité pour la classe moyenne et sur
un gouvernement ouvert et transparent
pourtant le bureau du premier ministre
n'a pas retourné nos appels
il a ministre du revenu a décliné notre
demande d'entrevue
alors nous nous sommes présentés au bal
des neiges d'ottawa où il prononçait un
discours
ben écoute et actuellement c'est un site
en litige on est encore un processus de
cours dans ce dossier là ça fait vous
comprendrez que je peux pas me permettre
le départ d'anne et aucun commentaire
faute sur mer la ministre du revenu
national a un pouvoir discrétionnaire
lui permettant d'annuler des pénalités
imposées à des contribuables
duane below estime que si l' agence du
revenu a posé ce geste pour les riches
clientes kpmg
elle devrait le faire pour ses clients
aussi donc je demanderai à la ministre
de regarder les faits de revisiter les
faits de fait ce corps arbitral et de
voir si les pénalités peut être éliminés
comme ici si ces canadiens qui sont
riches peut avoir un enfant secret
pourquoi ce qu'ils peuvent faire ça avec
d'autres clients
puisque l' agence du revenu à refuser
toute entente avec ses clients duane
below n'a plus d'autre choix que de
plaider leur cause devant la cour pour
jolène guignard et rémy coller ce
traitement qui semble inéquitable et
bien difficile à avaler
ces attitudes des sommes aussi indiqué
qu'on a fait est accepté on va tout
perdre se sait pas c'est pour un montage
au coeur qu'on peut payer
on va tout perdre
après six ans d'attentes jollet ni rémy
ont finalement fait face au fisc en
cours de l'impôt la semaine dernière
leur sort est désormais entre les mains
d'un juge